all right how's everyone feeling
let's try to do this like a lightning
talk too maybe we can
no wait where don't cut us off with a
flaws please
um okay
these are closing notes I'm your
outgoing chair Lauren alja like to
introduce you to the hopefully let's
make sure we really welcome him to 2023
executive Adventure
[Applause]
okay
oh gosh these have animation I don't I
didn't know that all right
um so we had four Keynotes 79 talks and
tutorials and 13 extra uh 84 speakers
this year 675 attendees the most tickets
ever registered for a pie Day At A New
York event
wait 39 diversity Scholars
do you wanna yeah you gotta do you gotta
talk too man yep uh I already had a mic
yep so we have 39 diversity Scholars and
16 sponsors uh more on that later as the
slide says and we have one Community
sponsors Lauren could you elaborate
thank you Pearson
[Applause]
all right and we had 20 core organizers
um I think most of us are in the room
all right at 24 volunteers thank you
everyone for volunteering and thank you
organizers
we have five non-focus employees and one
executive driver uh director on the
event thank you
all right and we also had five program
committee members and two program chairs
two of us here five behind the scenes oh
no that's in addition to us we're the
executors
yeah no there's Fortress total I take
that back uh 33 proposal readers uh five
to six projects in a response depends on
whether you account like conda slash
condo Forge we'll count it and say six
six all right and we had 32 attendees on
our Sprints and five PR submitted
we played 15 cold tools matches thanks
to Nathan Chinmay and Nathan's mom from
bringing for bringing them all the way
to from California to New York and I got
to draw with Thomas Castle so
thank you one more time
we did three speed mentoring sessions uh
for our diversity Scholars and the
larger attendee community
all right how many survey respondents
have we had uh trick question you're
gonna be getting this in your inbox so
don't forget to fill in the post
conference survey it'll be sent out Jim
when's it gonna get us next week next
week
all right
2022 is a year of major accomplishments
so it's the return to in-person events
after a two-year Hiatus that's a big one
we tried some new things
you want to know what did we try we
tried speed mentoring we tried photo
booths we did called tools and returned
up to Classic socials
book giveaways which is still pending um
birds of a feather I hosted one no one
showed up uh I'll pick a better title
next year and we did Pop Quiz a quiz
it's always a favorite yep Community
participation we co-located Sprints here
on Tuesday and we had more diversity
scholarships than ever before beating
our previous best record of 30 in 2019.
so by data I use the educational
Outreach and fundraising program of
non-focus this year Pi data NYC raised
over 100k in support of Open Source
scientific Computing put your hands
together
all right events like Pi data and YC are
not only critical for building Community
but contribute directly to the financial
sustainability of the projects so thank
you for being part of that thank you
everyone for being a part of it
so what was your favorite com part of
the conference so far engine I think
I've said it too many times now
yeah Thomas is already laughing I I
believe it's because you did not lose to
Thomas Caswell and killer duels unlike
everyone else that attempted
right right okay good good so
um what was everyone else's favorite
part yeah everyone all at once come on
Lightning talk
I think it was because of DMC right
right right
yeah there we go best MC
and join us in thanking our sponsors who
put this together made it all possible
so uh especially our host Microsoft and
our diamond and platinum sponsors CBS
Health Anaconda notable uh posit used to
be our studio kwanzai typo
is that how you say it taipai hopsworks
entropy block science we got a lot of
big ones this year Shopify deep Graham
two Sigma and our gold sponsors
thank you sponsors
and also finally our attendees you're
the attendees
thank you so much everyone
2023 or hopefully
Global is next month
and the pi data NYC Meetup is uh
everyone can get involved awesome where
is it
here oh here
as I already know how to get to the pi
data yeah we don't have anything on the
calendar yet but if you go to meetup.com
Pi data NYC you can sign up there and
get on the mailing list no thanks
everyone this is it thank you
until tutorials tomorrow see ya